it's one of the most highly anticipated
fights of the earth but the boxing
itself looks set to be overshadowed
Antony Joshua's attempt to recapture his
world titles from Andi Ruiz it's set to
happen this December in Saudi Arabia
it's the decision that's drawn criticism
following the killing of journalist
Jamal Kakashi last year inside the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul and the military
campaign in Yemen by a saudi-led
coalition which human rights groups have
accused of carrying out indiscriminate
attacks on homes hospitals and
marketplaces in a statement Amnesty
International said if Anthony Joshua
fights
Andy Ruiz jr. in Saudi Arabia it's
likely to be yet another opportunity for
the Saudi authorities to try to sports
wash their severely tarnished image
Saudi Arabia has still managed to secure
a number of huge events in the country
despite the criticisms former unified
world champion Aamir Khan was paid
millions to fight in Jeddah last month
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia invites the
world in 2018 World Wrestling
Entertainment staged their first event
there as part of a 10-year deal worth
that reported four hundred and fifty
million dollars Saudi Arabia has also
agreed a five-year deal to host the
Dakar Rally
however criticism and pressure has seen
some events called off Novak Djokovic
and Rafael Nadal pulled out of an
exhibition last December the match would
have seen them net 1 million dollars
each nonetheless for the Joshua match it
seems business interests have prevailed
they will say that it was a business
decision it's based on the money he's
gonna earn there it will be as hard and
cold as that I think it's just
stretching new ground new boundaries for
these very big fights there's gonna be a
lot of complaining for a lot of time
they'll go into camp and there'll be a
lot of complaining just before the fight
but loads of fans will still tune in
because Anthony Joshua is big news
Amnesty International has urged Joshua
to find out more about Saudi Arabia's
human rights record
but with the country investing 100
million dollars in the fight and with
both fighters expected to earn millions
themselves it seems difficult to see
anybody pulling out Sohail malik al
jazeera